[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv 78 merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette nouvelle édition de
78 tours cette émission dédiée aux
yvelines son patrimoine ses richesses
ses curiosités ans et ses curiosités ses
habitants également émission un peu
particulière en cette fin d'année nous
allons parler et des fêtes nous allons
aussi revenir sur les événements
marquants de 2021 patrice carmouze
justin brasilia gars de son groupe pour
ce soir merci à tous les trois vous
allez ma compagne pour cette émission et
patrice vous allez revenir sur les
personnalités qui ont marqué l'année
notamment dans les domaines économique
et politique est politique et peut-être
même
culturelle puisque j'ai une famille que
je vous parlerai aussi bien par la
famille lefebvre oui c'est un signe que
je dis pas qui c'est on va faire le
tambour après famille qui a fait
l'actualité encore et ses
talents et qui font ils sont tournés ils
ont fait un livre ils sont formidables
et vous les avez rencontré justine de
votre côté vous allez nous emmener à la
rencontre des producteurs locaux on
parlera gastronomie et puis vous allez
nous expliquer comment passer un noël
solidaire exactement parce que la fin de
l'année c'est aussi moment comme vous
l'avez dit d'être solidaire et j'ai
trouvé quelques petites idées pour vous
justement pour faire des bonnes actions
voilà donc y en a pour tous les goûts et
je vous montrerai ça tout à l'heure
célia de votre côté noël rime avec
bergerie de rambouillet c'est sa
bergerie nationale de rambouillet je
suis allé je suis à lille après un
après-midi de nombreuses animations
ateliers pour les enfants et aussi pour
les adultes beaucoup de rendez-vous au
cours de cette émission nous recevrons
aussi la société blinoise cocktail games
et ses jeux de société notamment une
édition pour les plus de 18 ans du
classique topten vous connaissez le top
ten oui très bien et bien là c'est un
top ten 18 plus lente et moins chanter
18 plus c'est pour adultes
c'est vrai un peu à 18 mois je te
plusieurs
années
avec nous et puis on
rencontre aussi avec l'équipe du film
super héros malgré lui c'était une
comédie qui sortira en février 2000 22
portées par un philippe lachaux
yvelinois d'origine il a présenté ce
film en avant-première dans nombreux
salah du territoire on va débuter pour
le moment avec le premier volet de notre
rétrospective 2021 dans les yvelines les
événements marquants du premier
trimestre et s'est signée gregory canal
et
la riposte s'organise contre le coc u19
début janvier les premiers centres de
vaccination ouvrent dans le département
comme à saint quentin en yvelines où le
vélodrome se transforme progressivement
en vaccinodromes des centres et qu'ils
seront même mobile levac six bus du
conseil départemental sillonne les
routes pour aller au contact des
habitants des zones rurales la campagne
se veut progressive les pharmacies se
joignent à l'effort avec un peu de
retard dû à la suspension temporaire du
vaccin astrazeneca les yvelinois qui
vivent au rythme des mesures sanitaires
du gouvernement un couvre-feu passant à
18 heures des grands centres commerciaux
fermés notamment un délit zee 2 ou
encore 3e confinement décrété au
printemps pour quatre semaines pendant
ce temps là les restaurants bars ou
encore lieu culturel reste fermé
le tribunal administratif de versailles
annuler les élections municipales de
2020 à trappes en cause le rejet des
comptes de campagne du maire élu ali
rabais la décision sera confirmée en
août par le conseil d'état les
trappistes revoteront en octobre trappe
victime de l'emballement médiatique
après les propos de didier lemaire le
professeur de philosophie au lycée de la
plaine de neauphle parle d'une ville
définitivement perdue est sous emprise
islamiste menace et il quittera
l'éducation nationale pour contrer la
polémique le rappeur saint quentinois
kirtas sortira le morceau trappe qui
donne une image positive de la ville
[Musique]
renault lance arnaud lucioles usine de
flins sur seine sera spécialisé dans
l'économie circulaire le technocentre de
guyancourt accueillir à la software et
publics pour penser avec d'autres
entreprises le véhicule de demain c'est
l'une des mesures du grenelle des
violences conjugales le bracelet anti
rapprochement est déployée dans les
yvelines une convention a été signée au
tribunal administratif de versailles le
latmos installé à guyancourt au coeur de
l'actualité spatiale lancement de son
anneau satellite ubs cussac pour
observer le soleil et la terre
le laboratoire a également développé
l'outil super calmes du rover
persévérance qui va collecter des
échantillons de la planète mars côté
sport le pistard grégory baugé prend sa
retraite celle yvelinois tire sa
révérence après neuf titres de champion
du monde et quatre médailles olympiques
la performance de louis burton le
skipper de rambouillet termine 3e du
vendée globe sur son bateau bureau
vallée et pour la douzième année
consécutive le paris-nice été lancés des
yvelines la course cycliste a démarré de
saint cyr l'école avant de prendre le
départ le lendemain de la petite commune
doivent ils sur mansion
enfin ils nous ont quittés au premier
semestre 2021 jean gombert maire de bois
d'arcy entre 89 et 95 le sergent yvonne
huisne tués au mali était né à trappes
marielle de sarnez eurodéputés d'île de
france pendant 17 ans la comédienne
catherine rich dont les obsèques se sont
déroulées à orgeval le sculpteur gérard
amon auteur de nombreuses oeuvres à
maurepas et olivier dassault fondateur
de génération entreprise et nous
poursuivrons la rétro 2021 tout au long
de cette émission 78 tours eux aussi ont
fait à l'actualité c'était il ya tout
juste un an décembre 2020 la famille
lefebvre famille versaillaise remporté
la finale de la france a un incroyable
talent émission qui est diffusée encore
aujourd'hui un sur m6 patrice vous les
avez rencontré parce que pour eux
l'aventuré ne s'est pas arrêté là une
aventure de cette part était j'avais
rencontré année gabriel les parents est
ce pas et pas les six enfants contre
d'asseoir les tentes ou dans cette
famille un seul maïs au 8e et absolument
ils sont tournées dans toute la france
était à lille à hier enfin du nord au
sud
ça se passe très bien ça marche très
bien ils ont fait un disque qui
s'appelle advitam aux cycles et qui
parle très bien et puis un livre un
livre qui s'appelle dans le coeur dans
le cadre la
khl la famille lefebvre etc oui oui
c'est très touchant parce qu'il ne
triche pas c'est pas des gens qui
trichent ici ce sera on tels qu'ils sont
il raconte l'heureux leur spiritualité
l'importance de la spiritualité
ils ont commencé à chanter ensemble
parce que le soit il priait voilà donc
ils racontent parfois on pourrait être
gêné mais en même temps ils font pas de
prosélytisme me disais c'est nous qu'on
me prenait pas personne n'est obligé de
faire que comme nous non ils sont très
cash je crois que c'est ça d'ailleurs
qui a acquis play qui appelait plus et
je pense que c'est ça qui est aussi
expliqué en dehors de leur talent et de
2,2 des chants sacrés qu'il faisait et
qui ont sans doute touché beaucoup de
gens je crois que c'est ça qui explique
aussi lors de leur succès dans
l'émission la france a un incroyable
talent donc je les ai rencontrés
y rien un livre je vous dis bien un
petit truc qui très bien dans ce deal on
sait qui on le voit que leur code voilà
donc vous pouvez écouter la musique si
vous voulez télécharger ça sur votre sur
votre ça fonctionne très bien à bien
donnez moi le livre vous allez voir
que vous ayez un smartphone de
sa part ajouté ça s'ouvre voilà
abbaye sainte marie la grâce
daly patrice on arrive à faire
fonctionner des tests en plateau des
fautes c'est très bien c'est batman je
sais bien effectivement il faut graisser
il y en a tout au long du livre imaginé
voilà c'est pas forcément qui chanta
c'est aussi des shows qui les ont
inspirés qu'ils aiment et c'est donc
c'est bien vous pouvez dire en écoutant
de musique danse et très très bien une
très bonne idée chose on va l'étude
datée de deux ânes siam qui l'a suggéré
de la mère de famille qui avait suggéré
aux éditeurs cds éditions la renaissance
plan voilà donc je les ai rencontrés on
regarde un petit extrait payer
l'addition est un peu plus longue à la
retenue et qui ont notre santé en replay
aussi sur notre site internet
l'intégralité de l'échangé avec la
famille lefebvre mené par patrice on ne
regarde un extrait dans ses émissions
évidemment il ya différents candidats
qui sont parfois un peu des archétypes
alors vous n'aurez plus dire au fond
c'est l'archétype de la famille
versaillaise classique nombreuses
et mais au fond
cela vous avez été je crois très fort ce
qu'est ce qui vous a amené la sympathie
du public et du jury si vous avez
toujours été vous même ce que je disais
vous n'avez jamais renier vos valeurs
pour faire de la télé on a eu droit à
tous et oui comment le dire c'est
possible
c'était assez humoristique donc c'était
finalement
on savait qu'on se prêtait à l'exercice
ea
prêter le flanc à ce genre de remarque
mais c'est vrai que on l'a assumé ce
qu'on est et voilà ça je pense que
c'était on était hors de question de
faire semblant et donc on avait hâte de
chanter oui oui vous ce qui vous
plaisait le plus c'était de chanter mais
b faut reconnaître que la production
était très sympathique avec vous les
animateurs aussi il n'y a pas eu comme
ça d' instrumentalisation ou de choses
comme ça ce qui aurait pu être le cas
parfois la télévision à ça arrive oui
bah c'est sûr que ça aurait pu mais la
production nous a pris vraiment au
sérieux après il nous a pris tel qu'on
était donc on se sentait en confiance
le jury quand on arrive sur scène il ne
sait pas qui en est il nous voit pas il
ne connaît pas ils ne découvrent donc ça
aurait pu nous hisser sélectionné comme
il ya un sélectionneur vague et il ya
des gens qui sélectionne voilà effilée
des jo d'hiver tizi billets près après
mont louis
et valla et ça a fonctionné donc on est
hyper content enfin on est vraiment très
heureux l'intégralité de cet échange que
vous avez mené patrice est donc à revoir
sur notre antenne et sur notre site
internet en replay on passe aux
décorations de fin d'année si on parle
de noël on parle décoration on a décoré
un petit peu ce plateau d'ailleurs c'est
lire c'est vous qui peut décorer le
plateau il à sa fin voilà on a des très
jolis sapins sur le plateau vous avez
des corps est chez vous imagine
encore à la dernière minute mais jamais
ils ont de la dernière minute est ce que
vous êtes fan de décoration ou c'est le
strict minimum et pure et simple des
décorations il en fait partie tout comme
les yvelinois que nous avons rencontré
aussi aime beaucoup embellir leur maison
pendant l ai fait regardez ce reportage
à la nuit tombée les maisons de la rue
de l'ancienne mairie à montigny le
bretonneux s'illuminent pour laisser
place à la féerie de noël une licorne
des champignons ou encore des pingouins
venue du pôle nord bienvenue sandrine
est ravi de partager ses décorations
avec les passants gros bonhommes de
neige que vous pouvez voir avec ces
petits flocons ensuite on passe par le
petit passage nous avons la famille de
serre le papa et la maman et son bébé
des décorations qui représente tout de
même un budget conséquent d'un budget
les rênes et ses 150 euros ou à peu près
le bonhomme de neige aussi
oui je l'avais eu chez gifi en 50 % vous
avez acheté après les après les
décorations faites quand ils solder tous
et la décoration lidl 8 euros et chaque
année sandrine enrichit un peu plus sa
collection le but est également
d'illuminer le visage des enfants qui
passent devant sa maison se trouve que
c'est plus gai et en plus comme on
habite juste en face l'école mais les
enfants ça leur permet de d'égayer un
peu leur fin d'année qui avec cette
année une copie d'un peu compliqué je
trouve que c'est un peu de joie dans ce
monde un peu compliqué à 48 heures de
noël les passants de la rue de
l'ancienne mairie peuvent encore
patienter en lumière avant de retrouver
leurs cadeaux au pied du sapin
nous avons vu les décorations de fin
d'année mais en fin d'année rime c'est
joli ça vous a plu oui bénéfique vous
avez trouvé décidé bas et je vais
m'inspirer de regarder le deuxième fois
pour être bien sûr c'est aussi les fêtes
de fin d'année l'occasion de faire des
bons repas et les yvelines le
département ne manque pas de richesse le
nombre de producteurs est assez
impressionnant de producteurs locaux on
va en vous faisant partager quelques
qu'elle quelques-uns célia vous êtes
allé à poissy j'ai rencontré suzanne et
jean françois ardouin ils sont éleveurs
bio ils font aussi ils sont artisans
bouchers charcutiers depuis 20 ans leur
élevage se situe en normandie c'est pour
ça d'où l'appellation la ferme
biologique de normandie mais leurs
ateliers de découpe se situe apprécié et
donc on peut producteurs de viande vous
les avez rencontré voici la séquence
[Musique]
ici on est à poissy à la ferme
biologique de normandie ou 18 rue des
capucines on est producteur la ferme
biologique de normandie ont fait de la
viande en bio depuis trois générations
sur la ferme pionnier en agriculture
biologique
le respect du bien-être de l'animal
et de la bonne viande qu'on fait et on
arrive demain en fin d'année 2021 les
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année en famille
enfin
donc voilà les premiers produits phares
de la ferme biologique de normandie un
beau chapeau à déguster en famille
pommes de terre pruneaux marron voilà
efficace et rapide voilà est autrement
on a également pour les familles plus
petit le rôti de dinde safri aux
pruneaux t'énerver avec une bonne farce
de vols intérieurs nourries à l'herbe
voilà voilà en plein air à déguster
pareil avec tonnes de terre oignons
bruno marie voilà qu'à une bonne
dégustation des produits de la ferme
biologique de normandie plusieurs
producteurs locaux seront à découvrir
tout au long de cette émission les
producteurs locaux qui ont été aussi à
l'honneur il ya quelques jours quelques
semaines jours l'assemblée nationale
avec le député philippe benassaya qui
avait réuni comme ça un certain nombre
de producteurs
des yvelines la sorte blair il va
montrer leurs produits il va monde fou
qui s'est précipitée des quilles à
manger
mais c'était une très belle initiative
je trouve de regrouper tous ces
producteurs et ça montre en effet qu'il
ya dans la boucherie mais il y avait
aussi des gens qui font des salaisons de
ce monde de f1 il vivait tous des
déconfitures ddd vivent maintenant dans
les yvelines et du vin absolument du vin
avec une superbe bouteille des cas ils
ont le droit avec la tour eiffel dessus
et faille et une bouteille qui est
absolument magnifique vous la conseille
quand même des bouches du roi que je dis
cet artiste et voilà donc tous et tous
ces producteurs étaient réunies et geste
était vraiment très très sympathique
évidemment mais mais très bien aussi
pour le pour la production des yvelines
on va en découvrir d'autres tout au long
de cette émission pour l'instant
deuxième partie de notre rétro 2021 le
second le deuxième trimestre que s'est
il passé au cours de ces trois mois
voici le résumé
face à la troisième vague de lakovic 19
emmanuel macron décide de fermer les
écoles les collèges qui sait écrire
pendant trois semaines le cours se font
donc à la maison pendant ce temps là la
vaccination bat son plein au vélodrome
plus de cinquante mille personnes ont
été vaccinées en avril la vente des
autotests a été autorisée en pharmacie
les officines ont subi au début un
manque d'approvisionnement malgré les
dépistages en constat alarmant plus de
cent mille personnes sont décédées de
lakovic 19 triste record le 22 avril la
crise sanitaire fait chuter la
fréquentation touristique dans les
yvelines près de 50% de baisse dans les
séjours hôteliers plus de 60 % de
visites dans les sites touristiques et
en parlant d'entreprises en difficulté
le département des yvelines a soutenu
l'entreprise donne le pilot près de deux
millions de veaux ont été avancées par
le département un budget permettant aux
nouveaux repreneurs finadorm de ne pas
payer les murs de sa structure le 23
avril les yvelines sont de nouveau
touchée par le terrorisme fonctionnaire
de police âgé de 49 ans stéphanie
m'enfermer a été tué lors d'une attaque
au couteau devant son commissariat
rambouillet quelques jours plus tard un
hommage national lui a été rendu
une restauration intégrale au château de
versailles la chapelle royale a subi
trois ans de travaux un nom pour le
cabinet donc le du roi qui sont
désormais comme neufs le mois de mai est
synonyme de déconfinement pour les
yvelinois le 3 mai marque la première
étape fin de la limitation des 10 km le
19 mai deuxième phase du quai
confinement les commerces non essentiels
et les lieux culturels ont pu rouvrir
avec des jauges réduite les bars et
restaurants eux peuvent à nouveau
accueillir des clients en extérieur
côté sport pendant trois jours le linxea
open était organisée au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines par la
fédération française de golf 120
sportifs amateurs aux professionnels
étaient rassemblées dont le numéro deux
français antoine cros maire
quarante élèves du lycée saint françois
d'assise de montigny le bretonneux ont
suivi un échange en direct avec
l'astronaute français thomas pesquet
depuis l'observatoire de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines côté politique
les élections départementales et
régionales avaient lieu les 20 et 27
juin valérie pécresse garde la tête de
la région ile de france concernant les
départements des yvelines c'est le
groupe ensemble pour les yvelines menés
par pierre bédier majorité de droite et
du centre qui a remporté les 21 cantons
du département au cours de ce deuxième
trimestre de l'année on retiendra cette
disparition le cycliste robert marchand
s'est éteint le 25 mai à 109 ans le
centenaire a battu plusieurs records de
l'heure sur la piste du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines à
105 ans il avait parcouru environ 22 km
en 1h
78 tours se poursuit à présent avec
notre personnalité sportive de l'année
les journalistes sportifs de tv soixante
dix huit se sont réunis ils ont délibéré
leur verdict on retrouve grégory canale
et il s'agit d'arthur rinderknecht c'est
donc notre sportif yvelinois de l'année
il est avec nous par visioconférence
bonjour arthur salut salut à tous merci
d'être avec nous puisque votre saison a
été pleine elle a été longue et vient
maintenant le temps du repos du guerrier
alors pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent
pas vous êtes tennisman vous avez 26 ans
et vous avez été formé au tennis club
des loges de saint germain en laye en
2021 vous avez connu une ascension folle
puisque vous étiez en début d'année au
delà de la 170e place mondiale et vous
êtes aujourd'hui le 58e joueur mondial
le quatrième français quel regard
portez-vous sur cette année 2021 est ce
que vous vous attendiez appareils
ascension d'intégrer finalement ce top
100 mondial non évidemment c'est assez
inespéré maintenant c'est sûr que c'est
une très belle année pour moi je peux
pas m'en plaindre surtout une année
voilà au milieu d'une dune anr colis qui
évidemment pas simple avec pas mal de
restrictions mais très très content de
cette année est vraiment impatient
d'attaquer l'année prochaine avec une
cerise sur le gâteau c'est cette
participation avec l'équipe de france a
à la coupe davis vous avez été a
sélectionné par sébastien grosjean alors
les bleus ont été éliminés au premier
tour il ya une victoire contre la
république tchèque puis une défaite
contre la grande bretagne vous avez
d'ailleurs participé à ce duel contre
les britanniques votre bilan c'est une
défaite 6-2 7-6 contre cameron nouri le
12e joueur mondial et une victoire aussi
en double au côté de nicolas mahut que
retenez vous de cette expérience est ce
que il ya un côté frustrant parce que
contre cameron nouri vous étiez passé
tout proche dans le second set
d'arracher justement ce set a eu deux
balles de set où justement vous préféré
retenir et bien l'expérience acquise
grâce à cette coupe davis non évidemment
la coupe davis même la nomination ma
sélection était vraiment la cerise sur
le gâteau de cette fin d'année pour moi
qui l'eût cru en début d'année que je
ferai partie de cette équipe de coupe
davis je pense personne et moi le
premier donc c'était vraiment une
superbe expérience et j'adorais y
recourent mais je vais tout faire pour
maintenant oui le match de simple et
assez serré j'ai pas joué la première
rencontre je vous la deuxième face aux
anglais et c'était 1 il fallait
absolument gagner pour se qualifier
alors on a perdu 2 1 à c'est assez serré
j'aurais aimé faire un petit peu mieux
en simple maintenant j'ai joué un très
bon adversaire 12e c'est sur que c est
ce que ce qu'il se fait de mieux dans le
monde donc ce n'était pas simple pour un
premier match avec avec la tension et
tout ce qui va avec mais j'ai fait le
maximum et on a réussi à gagner un très
beau double avec nicolas mahut dans la
foulée face à face à deux joueurs
britanniques qui sont placés dans l'est
dans les vingt premiers mondiaux donc
nous c'était un très bon nous beaucoup
d'autres choses pour vous également
cette année vous avez participé au
premier tour de roland garros c'était
déjà le cas la saison dernière premier
tour également à wimbledon et vous avez
même atteint le second tour de l'us open
cette année vous avez aussi un titre sur
cette année 2021 au tournoi d'istanbul
tournois challengers en début d'année
sur le circuit atp votre bilan cette
saison ses 18 victoires 16 défaites en
2021 plusieurs quarts de finales dans
des tournois atp vous avez battu aussi
deux joueurs du top 20 mondial
l'espagnol roberto bautista gouttes lors
du tournoi de gstaad est aussi l'italien
yannick sinner qui est un peu aussi
l'une des pépites du moment du tennis
mondial c'est quoi votre meilleur
souvenir sur cette année deux de ses
sept années 2000 21 c'est sûr que ces
deux victoires et été assez particulière
pour moi mes deux premiers top 20 des
joueurs voilà immense que son que son
seul l'italien et l'espagnol j'ai
l'habitude de les voir à la télé là
j'arrive à les battre sur des sur des
vrais gros tournoi tu étais donc
évidemment que c'est assez fantastique
maintenant oui découvrir wimbledon
m'être qualifié avoir mon premier tour a
lâché sur le gazon londonien de
wimbledon c'était assez fantastique
alors j'ai perdu un match assez fou
14 12 euros cinquième set mais avec une
balle de match mais mais c'était quand
même un super souvenir et puis oui ma
victoire aussi est assez assez
improbable à l us open au chu mené 2
sets 0 et je reviens pour gagner en cinq
sets en étant alors venir les crampes
aux jambes et et tout ce qui va avec
dans l'humilité de new york mais
c'étaient des super c ce sont les super
sonia et tout ça avec un parcours
atypique vous êtes arrivé tard sur le
circuit vous êtes professionnel depuis
2018 après des études aux états unis à
l'université du texas est ce que c'est
ça votre force finalement ce parcours
peut être qui vous donne moins de
pression vous avez été moins exposés que
d'autres joueurs français qui ont été
exposés très jeune est ce que c'est ça
le fait peut-être de jouer sans pression
avec ce parcours atypique finalement
c'est que du bonus non je joue pas sans
pression non plus je pense que tout le
monde en a maintenant c'est fait partie
de mon identité à ses 7 chemin voilà
c'est le chemin que j'ai pris celui
celui qui est qui m'a formé donc donc
évidemment j'en suis fier
non j'essaie voilà j'essaie d'apprendre
de chaque expérience et et les stages
ils m'ont beaucoup appris pour prendre
part à deux joueurs chacune alors vous
êtes grands vous faites un mètre 96 vous
avez une grosse envergure mais tout de
même une bonne mobilité deux points
forts c'est le service et le coup droit
sur quels aspects vous devez travailler
pour cette année 2022 et vous fixez
justement d'autres objectifs je vais pas
je vais pas tout vous dévoiler mais mais
non j'ai pas mal pas me toujours pas
malade axes de travail a
progressé à développer mon entraîneur on
en parlera en parlerait mieux que moi
mais mais oui point de vue physique
point de vue des placements vidal enfin
toujours toujours renforcé mon jeu dans
lequel j'essaye de de jouer ennuis mes
adversaires évidemment toujours là mieux
le faire plus plus en étant plus solide
est évidemment un gros objectif pour moi
et vos objectifs justement sur l'année
2022 est ce que vous voir dans un top 30
top 20 mondial est-ce que ça c'est
possible dès 2022
vous savez les classements moi je passe
je m'en moque parce qu'évidemment cas à
la fin de la fin de la journée ou à la
fin de l'année on regarde le classement
mais j'essaie surtout de travailler sur
mon jeu simon niveau 2 si mon niveau de
jeu progresse à ce moment là les
victoires viendront elle est si les
victoires viennent le classement pro
maintenant je vais pas me manger pas
vous donner de d'inside sur sur le
classement que que je rêverais d'avoir
et tout ça est encore bien sûr un rêve
parce que tel dans le top 30 c'est quand
même quelque chose assez assez
exceptionnel vous souhaite en tout cas
le meilleur merci arthur in darkness
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous et on
suivra bien sûr sur tv 60,18 vos
prochaines performances avec attention
[Musique]
bâle est un sujet qui lui mettra tout le
monde d'accord parce que j'imagine que
chacun à son sportif évinois de de
l'année voilà un sujet qui lui mettra
tout le monde d'accord c'est le noël à
la bergerie de rambouillet c'est à dire
j'y suis resté un après-midi la balle il
ya de multiples animations on débute
avec un atelier l'aiment et récup en
fait on a appris à créer un mobile de
noël j'étais en équipe avec un père de
famille et son enfant
vous avez des morceaux de laine qu'ils
sont de différentes tailles et la
ficelle marre on va vous permettre en
fait des tâches et
le bout de bois comme ceci pour faire la
petite accroche qu'on peut mettre au
sapin ou sur le mur et ensuite les
différentes à il va permettre de coller
les moteurs
alors c'est assez simple à réaliser une
activité ne sent pas lui dit que
affaires bilan sion en famille donc
jusqu'au 24 décembre on pouvait aussi de
faire des tours compter en calèche et
bien sûr rencontrer des boutons les
boutons mais le faire mourir dans la
crèche émetteurs laberge originaire la
crèche
l'occasion de découvrir des animaux les
mérinos les vaches ou encore les chevaux
c'est de voir finalement tous les
animaux dans les bâtiments ce que
beaucoup d'animaux sont dans les prés
pendant le printemps été automne et là
ils sont tous rentrés donc tous les
bâtiments sont pleins avec en plus
beaucoup de naissances d'agneau ans pour
moi est une activité qui va vous plaire
patrice la traite des vaches ah oui je
fais très bien ça moi j'ai rencontré
antoine fait alors non j'ai pas pu le
faire mais il m'a expliqué justement
faut vous y mettre oui lb si dieu geiger
temps break plus le deschaux oui mais
oui bah vous allez voir après la voix
vous êtes meilleur accueil vous soyez la
chronique là
j'ai rencontré anthony les vaches et à
la bergerie nez il explique justement
aux visiteurs comment cela fonctionne
vous allez peut-être nous expliquer la
crise
dans la salle de traite donc la première
étape serait de nettoyage et riom
ensuite la deuxième étape de tirer les
premiers donc on doit les protéger à la
mort donc pour s'assurer que l'arraché
en bonne santé alors sur mon chemin
également j'ai croisé la famille des
mots thomas ils ont participé à tous les
ateliers aimons partager leurs
expériences on avait fait un tour en
calèche et du coup un pont il y avait
une dame qui nous raconter une histoire
fait des casse noisette prompt à vue le
père noël
[Musique]
on a vu les moutons mérinos au cices
impressionnant on a fait des câlins la
aux petits aux petites chèvres donc non
c'est très sympa et les ateliers aussi
les enfants ont adoré et donc on finit
cet après midi avec une petite douceur
justement le chocolat chaud le les 100%
c'est avec le bas le lait de leur vache
donc c'est super voilà tu espères le
lait va ensuite dans un atelier de
transformation il est pasteurisé on le
récupère en saut ensuite on le
réchauffement rajoute un chocolat qu'on
achète un producteur local et vous
l'avez pas ramener non je n'ai pas
rallié en cette base les gouttes et je
les
sers du magnifique oui à l'étoile et du
coup je le rappelle à la bergerie
nationale est ouverte durant toutes les
vacances avec les différentes animations
justement que j'ai que je vous ai montré
sauf le 25 décembre et le 1er janvier là
ils sont fermés il faut pas hésiter à
aller les voir tous ces lieux culturels
ont besoin de fréquentation aussi c'est
difficile encore aujourd'hui il ya
toujours ces questions de passes
sanitaire mais ils seront ravis de vous
recevoir à rambouillet comme ailleurs à
travers le département dépaysement
programme ah oui alors c'est très bonne
journée oui c'est ça c'est là on a la
campagne bob justin on va poursuivre le
tour d'horizon des producteurs locaux
avec vous focus sur les deux gourmands à
présent oui ne sont que deux à être
gourmand ils sont alors ils sont pas que
de 1 franchement il y en avait partout
dans la boutique mais voilà les deux
gourmands en fait c'est une biscuiterie
et miellerie qui est basée à crêpière et
en fait c'est vraiment une histoire
d'amitié de base c'est pour ça qu'ils
s'appellent l'aide de gourmands c'est
une histoire ses deux amis qui se sont
lancés dans le circuit court et la
production locale est en fait donc vous
l'aurez compris produisent leur miel et
leurs biscuits mais travaille avec plein
d'autres producteurs locaux c'était ça à
l'essentiel pour eux et moi j'ai pu
découvrir la boutique mais aussi
l'atelier de fabrication
voilà je me laisse découvrir ça
bienvenue à la ferme chez les deux
gourmands je suis l'un des deux
guillaume logbo mans c'est lui mon
associé
[Musique]
à
je n'ai pas visité le site
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la boutique ici c'est ici
qu'ont commercialise tous nos produits
aux biscuits nominale de pain d épices
on a fait des mises en avant pour les
fêtes parce qu'on vend plein de coffrets
pendant les périodes de fin d'année pour
tous ceux qui ont envie de se régaler
avec de bons produits locaux on n'a même
pas des piscines aux tablettes de
chocolat les produits partenaires des
jus des pattes du thé et aussi plein
d'autres choses des spiritueux derrière
on a un petit peu de produits frais des
glaces et enfin au miel qu'on retrouve
ici et nos biscuits et maintenant on va
aller en fabrication ou vous faire
découvrir comment tout ça est fait donc
on est au coeur ici de la biscuiterie
c'est ici qu'on fabrique tous nos
produits nos biscuits et nos coûts qui
aujourd'hui qu'on retrouve à bord des
trains tgv inouïe donc on fait les
pesées ici ensuite on pétrit la pâte une
fois qu'on l'a pétri on va la façonner
on va donner la forme aux cookies on
dispose alors les cookies sur les
plaques mis sur des chariots on envoie
en cuisson et une fois que c'est cuit
suivez-moi
voilà à quoi
ça ressemble
vous l'avez pas là mais ça sent bon et
c'est délicieux et ccoo qui nous restent
ensuite pour finir à les mettre en
sachet avant de les mettre dans les
cartons puis les expédier et en sachet
ça ressemble à ça et pour la prochaine
séquence gastronomique nous irons dans
une brasserie cette fois ci à bois
d'arcy la brasserie o'clock que c'est
bien de manger bien de boire aussi dans
les crêtes avec modération comme
d'habitude tout cas rester avec nous on
va parler noël solidaire à présent la
fin de l'année c'est aussi l'occasion
plus que jamais d'être solidaire
solidaire envers les plus démunis
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme action
qu'est ce que vous nous conseillez g
vous dire ça dans quelques instants mais
juste avant je voudrais vous dire que en
fait c'est la magie de noël je pense
qu'ils opèrent parce que comme vous
l'avez dit on est plus solidaire je
pense que c'est aussi le fait qu'il ya
plus de sensibilisation on tombe sur les
personnes qui emballe les cadeaux à la
sortie des magasins et donc moi je me
suis demandé est justement si les
yvelinois était plus solidaire aussi au
moment de noël et je leur ai posé la
question regarder avec l'école les
cadeaux par exemple les noëls canadien
on note des choses qui font plaisir nos
caméras c'est le moment où on est un peu
plus généreux avec eux les associations
france en 7 jours sur 7 365 jours pour
cent plus obligé on va dire mais après
je pense que s'ils ont envie de gérer
nos actions prendra tous glanés quoi on
le fait aux naturellement normalement et
tout au long de l'année moi je travaille
en école donc après avec les enfants on
a fait des choses aussi avec les maisons
de retraite en lien avec les personnes
âgées on a fait des petites cartes etc
donc oui le complètement les yvelinois
les yvelinoises sont ouvertes ouvert à
la solidarité bons conseils mais
conseille donc y en a pour tous les
goûts pour faire des bonnes actions
marché juste là pour vous donner
quelques petites idées si vous avez un
peu de temps déjà être présent c'est
aussi être solidaire passer du temps
avec votre entourage ou encore des
personnes isolées savoir que c'est pas
ultra pas si lancement avec la crise
sanitaire mais voilà si vous avez la
possibilité prouve également faire du
tri dans vos vêtements les jouets de vos
enfants et et faire don de tout ça je
pense notamment à emmaüs emmaüs ou
encore le secours populaire avec ses
pères noël verts en fait qui font des
collectes pour les plus démunis c'est
bien de sensibiliser à travers les
enfants aussi de faire le tri avec eux
ça leur apprend aussi ça devient naturel
pour le coup après dieu aussi d'être
d'être solidaires comme exactement et
c'est hyper important s'il fait
important et puis je vous propose aussi
l'opération offrir une boîte solidaire
pour noël simplement vous pouvez prendre
une petite boîte à chaussures et vous
déposer quelque chose de chaud par
exemple comme des gants et un bonnet
quelque chose à manger mais non
périssables et puis loisirs par exemple
un livre un produit d'hygiène une brosse
à dents et puis voilà après la croix
rouge française il y en a beaucoup qui
le font mais la croix rouge française
vous permet de le faire jusqu'au 8
janvier ou encore le faire
faux déposée fin des wii dans les
pyramides unités locales auraient déposé
dans une unité de la croix rouge voilà
jusqu'au 8 janvier et ce sera distribué
pendant les marottes du coup de début
d'année ça c'est pour ceux qui
s'impliquent qui veulent fabriquer qui
donnent de leur temps beaucoup aussi
ceux qui ont un petit peu moins de temps
c'est pas une excuse mais oui aussi des
possibilités
vous pouvez totalement faire don juste
un peu d'argent si vous avez ça se fait
facilement en ligne ça prend pas
beaucoup de temps et si vous avez des
cadeaux à offrir je vous propose un site
ses boutiques solidaires en fait c'est
un site qui regroupe plein
d'associations caritatives et là vous
pouvez faire vos achats par exemple
pourrait trouver des timbres de l'unicef
les cartes de voeux du secours populaire
ou encore les cadres il l'espère donc ça
c'est moi j'étais calendrier de l'unicef
les liens tard via domitia vous avez
plein de choses entre la sonde dessus
c'est bien on fait des bonnes actions
célia réveille chez frère de vous
et puis il revient chaque année depuis
trente ans je pense que vous le
connaissez pas comme ça qu'est ce lapin
sac à sapin c'est les sacs à sapin
d'handicap international
c'est un sac biodégradable 5 euros 1
euro 50 reversés du coup aux actions de
l'association et puis elle permet
l'insertion des personnes atteintes de
handicap donc c'est vachement solidaires
et c'est très utile et c'est très utile
sur you surtout pendant cette période je
voulais juste vous rappeler que
l'important d'être pour être solidaire
c'est que chacun puisse faire ce qu'il a
envie de faire que ce soit donné de son
temps ou de l'argent voilà chacun
participe à sa façon il s'apprend pas
forcément beaucoup de temps quand on
passe dans un magasin de prendre le sac
à sapin par exemple voilà on leur montre
vous l'utiliserez bien sûr nouvelle
pause dans ce 78 tours de fin d'année
nous allons revenir sur la suite des
événements qui ont marqué 2021 c'est
avec michael ennemis devront à présent
l'été blinois 2021 et et sportif avec
les jeux olympiques de tokyo 11 athlètes
y vit - participer à cet événement
planétaire mention spéciale aux trois
triathlètes de poissy qui remporte la
médaille de bronze tout comme
christopher six ans l'équitation le
versailles et valentin porte handball et
guillaume chaîne de sartrouville
remporte la médaille d'or les jeux de
tokyo à peine refermées tous les regards
sont désormais tournés vers les jo de
2024 à paris le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli en
septembre le passage du drapeau
olympique dans sa structure du cyclisme
également dans les yvelines avec le tour
de france la dernière étape est parti
depuis château taddei chpo gars de char
vainqueur de cette édition 2021 et
julian alaphilippe étaient présents sur
la ligne de départ
côté politique le conseil d'état a
tranché il faudra revoter pour les
élections municipales attrape le maire
élu en 2020 à lire à bas été sanctionné
suite à les infractions pendant sa
campagne les dates des nouvelles
élections les 10 et 17 octobre de son
côté valérie pécresse a annoncé sa
candidature pour les élections
présidentielles de 2022 l'ancien député
des yvelines venait d'être réélu pour un
second mandat à la tête de la région ile
de france depuis le 21 janvier il est
obligatoire de présenter un pass
sanitaires pour accéder aux lieux de
loisirs et de culture comme les musées
will cinéma les salles obscures ont
enregistré une chute de la fréquentation
de 70% le pass sanitaire devient
également obligatoire à partir du 9 août
pour aller manger au restaurant attrape
première étape pour le chantier de
l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 le
pont marcel cachin était démolie dans la
nuit du 17 au 18 août il surplombe et la
n 10 au niveau de la mairie le chantier
d'envergure devrait durer six ans en
septembre le musée départemental maurice
denis installé à saint germain les
rouvre ses portes après trois ans de
travaux le jardin et le bâtiment était
restauré une exposition inaugurale
dédiée à l'artiste peintre a été réalisé
le week-end des 11 et 12 septembre le
château de versailles accueillait la
plus grande reconstitution historique
d'époque 400 passionnés en fait revivre
napoléon ce bicentenaire de l'empereur
l'électro également à l'honneur en ce
mois de septembre après une édition 2009
1 annulée en raison de la crise
sanitaire électrique pack de château
était de retour des milliers de fêtards
en participer à cette 11e édition sur
deux jours à thouars et un rhinocéros
blanc arrive au parc zoologique son nom
voit katy trois ans après la mort de
vince a battu en 2018 par des
braconniers pour récupérer sa corne
enfin il nous a quittés en ce début
septembre après une immense carrière au
cinéma jean paul belmondo alias bébel
est décédé à l'âge de 88 ans le comédien
avait passé une partie de son enfance à
clairefontaine en yvelines pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale
on va rester dans l'actualité de l'année
écoulée avec vous patrice à présent
personnalités économiques de l'année eh
bien j'ai choisi guillaume cairou qui
est le nouveau président de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie des yvelines
parce que c'est un homme qui a un
jeune il a parcours assez atypique il
est né au val-fourré à mantes-la-jolie
quartier quartier difficile donc dans un
milieu c'est défavorisés après il a fait
des études de sciences des études de
d'éducation et puis il a commencé à
transmettre un peu de son savoir et
alors ils trouvaient que quand même
c'était c'était compliqué de
l'époque qui vais pas vous savez
d'auto-entrepreneur ça n'existait pas
donc c'était assez compliqué d'exercer
ce métier là il s'est retrouvé au
chômage et en 2004 il dit bajeux
faudrait bien bas ma boîte alors il
avait mille euros en poche en tout et
pour tout
aucune banque n'a voulu évidemment
l'aider il dit d'ailleurs que c'est
assez amusant parce que maintenant les
banques courent et lui pour savoir s'ils
voudraient pas à tout hasard vendre un
peu trop d'entreprises il est créé son
entreprise qu'apple d'idactis qui a
aujourd'hui 800 800 employés qui est une
entreprise de portage salarial alors
cette très dense on dans son univers
parce que le portage salarial ça permet
à des gens qui ont des contrats avec
fait qu'une société
d'être engagé par cette société par
d'idactis par une société de portage
salarial comme ça ils ont leur liberté
et ils ont la protection des salariés
donc c'est et c'est un peu son c'est un
peu ce sont son truc ça d'avoir à la
fois la liberté d'être un peu
entrepreneurs et salariés de protéger et
de pouvoir faire ce qu'on veut c'est
quelque chose qu'il a développés il a
d'ailleurs écrit pas mal de bouquins là
dessus il y avait tous indépendants
c'était son premier livre après il avait
changé de vie changer de job enfin
ribéry crypte pas mal de livres là
dessus il avait l'idée de sa création
d'entreprises déjà où il s'est juste dit
bon j'ai pas de boulot il faut que je
crée une entreprise ensuite je trouve
l'idée il voulait pouvoir exercer de
manière indépendante son travail d'où
cette idée de portage salarial et d'où
cette idée de créer sa société
donc il a été le paddy été élu à
l'unanimité président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie et alors il a
oui c'est ça ce tropisme de de dire au
fond il faudrait que les gens soient
deviennent des autres progressions son
dernier livre d'ailleurs s'appelle tous
entrepreneurs 1
il donne des conseils c'est parce qu'il
dit il ya plein de gens qui veulent
monter des boîtes qui ont un peu peur
qui se demande c'est vrai c'est pas
c'est pas facile il faut sauter le pas
ça fait et voilà on peut les aider c'est
d'ailleurs ça va être d'ailleurs un de
ses chantiers à la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie puisqu'un des buts qu'il
se propose ya à peu près entre c'est pas
ça dépend de la forme de prêt entre 58
et 88 entreprises dans les yvelines son
but est de doubler le nombre
d'entreprises pendant les cinq ans qui
viennent et de les faire durer aussi
tenter de les faire durer lui fallait
avec avec beaucoup parce que au fond il
ya beaucoup de grandes entreprises dans
les yvelines mais il ya beaucoup de pme
mais voilà mais le pourcentage est
le plus beau le coeur de de ces
entreprises et les tpe et les pme donc
c'est ça qui veut qu'il veut favoriser
et il y à déjà voilà plein de gens qui
ont des idées qui peuvent qui peuvent
faire leur boîte engager des gens y ait
des emplois qui se créent presque tous
les jours dans ce territoire et lui va
essayer des dessins on va l'écouter vous
l'avez rencontré il ya peu pour votre
émission contre lui demander aux faux
quel était son analyse justement après
la crise sanitaire quel était l'état des
entreprises dans les yvelines et si on
pouvait être optimiste quant à l'avenir
ce qui est intéressant
c'est pour les yvelines on a un certain
nombre effectivement 2
d'industrie
qui sont en perte de vitesse
l'automobile l'aéronautique
et un certain nombre d'industries autour
de la défense du fait de cette
transition écologique est en cours et de
l'autre on s'aperçoit qu'on a énormément
de nouveaux entrepreneurs qui ont tiré
parti finalement de 7 de cette pandémie
je rencontrais par exemple il ya
quelques il ya quelques jours un
chocolatier voyez c'est un des exemples
dont je parle souvent les métiers
manuels et qui a créé quand même c'est
dingue quinze emplois pendant la
pandémie donc des emplois sonnants et
trébuchants
donc c'est tout ça pour dire on va
devoir effectivement
soutenir nos grandes industries mais on
va surtout devoir soutenir nos petites
petites entreprises petits commerçants
petits entrepreneurs qui eux sont
réellement des créateurs d'emplois de
proximité et durable dans le temps donc
c'est un peu l'apprentissage de de cette
période voilà pour la personnalité
économique personnalité politique à
suivre tout à l'heure avec vous aussi
patrice on l'est on laisse de côté à
l'économie on passe à la culture à
présent avec le musée archéologique de
saint germain en laye
depuis 2001 18 ce le musée d'archéologie
nationale à saint germain en laye
accueille l'ensemble de musique de
chambre calliopée afin de faire
découvrir ses collections en musique
plusieurs projets sont nés de cette
rencontre certains a été inattendue
fruit de la situation sanitaire bonjour
karine lethiec merci d'être avec nous
directrice artistique de l'ensemble
calliopée on nous voulons profiter de
cette émission de fin d'année pour
évoquer avec vous ce projet musicaux
archéo il s'est déroulé sur l'année 2021
il va se prolonger sur l'année 2022 bien
sûr déjà comment est née cette idée de
faire se rencontrer l'archéologie et la
musique de chant et bien l'archéologie
ça raconte déjà notre histoire il ça
raconte surtout l'histoire de l'humanité
et finalement au ton regard toutes les
traces tout les signes que nous propose
l'archéologie on se rend compte que nous
les êtres humains nous ancêtres nous
sommes des musiciens eh oui la première
chose qu'on envoie à cette époque parce
que quand on parle d'archéologie on
parle la préhistoire est bien l'homme
préhistorique novo sapiens a laissé des
traces qui indique qu'il dessinait déjà
bien sûr dans les grottes dans les
grottes pariétal mais on a aussi
retrouvé des instruments notamment des
instruments de flêtre que nous avons à
saint germain en laye et on peut
imaginer aussi qu'il chantait et donc
c'est cette interrogation que nous
menons et que nous rendons le plus
vivant possible parce que s'intéresser à
notre histoire c'est aussi faire un lien
avec aujourd'hui avec les créateurs les
humains d'aujourd'hui qui ont envie de
continuer toujours en fait si génial
parce que l'homme est un créateur cette
créativité elle est en chacun d'entre
nous même si on n'est pas musicien
d'ailleurs il ya quelque chose
d'extraordinaire qui dont l'être humain
qui veut toujours se transcender et
c'est quand même quelque chose de
positif est que nous mettons en oeuvre
avec bien sûr toute l'équipe du musée
d'archéologie à travers différentes ma
discrétion des conseils il accélère des
visites en musique des ateliers aussi je
vais donner de dates de concerts à venir
27 mars 15 mais aussi donc 2022 ce sera
dans la chapelle
comment se construit la musique
justement avec le musée dans un musée
comment se fait la résonance entre les
deux alors eh bien par exemple le
concert donc on vous citez du 15 mai il
ya une dalle assez magique dans le
château parce que le musée d'archéologie
c'est aussi un château qui a toute une
histoire et bien tout au fond il ya une
balle mais qui est bien trop lourde
qu'on a déplacé alors nous avons eu
cette idée là deux semaines sur les
toits dominique de pierre qui dans
l'ombre et la lumière et donc de lui
offrir une musique spécialement dédiée
qui la suivront ce n'est elle a les
tracés qui sont une carte extraordinaire
on vient vous couvert c'était la
première carte au monde et de demander
un compositeur d'aujourd'hui est bien de
retranscrire cela sous forme d'une
musique que l'on peut offrir et ce qui
nous intéresse aussi c'est de n'offrir
d'une manière un peu
extraordinaire est donc là dans ce film
parce que c'est la version life ça sera
différent bien sûr je pense pas que je
vais inviter le public sont les toits
mais voilà c'était ça c'était la version
du visuel mais dans le cas du concert du
moi même serons dans la chapelle est un
endroit merveilleux pour l'acoustique
puisqu'il a été conçu autour de l'époque
de louis xiv vous savez qui aimait aussi
beaucoup la musique et la création
contemporaine et donc ça fait un écrin
magique pour écouter ses concerts
d'échangés avec le public on va revenir
sur ce spectacle ancêtres en tout cas
captation qui a eu lieu sur le sur le
toit du musée dans un instant va avoir
un extrait un petit peu plus mais juste
sur les moments des changes qui sont
aussi organisés et proposé dans ce cadre
là avec le public ces ateliers est ce
que vous pouvez nous parler un peu des
ateliers des lotos phone on va les voir
à l'image alors ces instruments les lys
aa vous dire mythos c'est la pierre est
fan ses leçons donc c'est la pierre qui
sonne ce sont les premiers instruments
préhistorique puisque ces pierres sont
du calcaire c'est les mêmes que celles
qui sont dans les grottes et alors tony
di napoli que vous voyez qui dans un
très grand créateur lescultes lui même
et va les faire chanter va les faire
vibrer en fait ils les caresses et du
coup ça fait une feinte de vibrations
c'est un show absolument fascinant qui
nous aident retrouvez cet environnement
sonore ont pendant les ateliers tony
montre aux familles aux enfants à toute
personne intéressée par même
l'acoustique cette merveilleuse
interactions entre une pierre finalement
donc purement la la la la pierre qui
devient un instrument ils tous les
effets sonores qu'elle peut qu'elle peut
donner donc les gens sont actrices
pendant l'atelier on y pense push et y
participer en dinapoli adore partager
mais lui même créateur
des heures avec ses lithophone alors je
reviens justement sur ce qu'on a pu voir
aussi tout à l'heure on parlait des
projets qui sont nés aussi pendant la
période de confinement et de covin il a
fallu donc réinventer vous avez pu faire
des captations on a vu quelques images
et on va en voir un extrait ce concert
filmé est aussi à découvrir en
intégralité sur votre chaîne youtube
l'adresse s'affichera bien évidemment
sur le sur l'antenne extrait de pierre
raconte hommage musical à la dalle de
saint bellec interprétation donc réalisé
sur les toits du musée
[Musique]
magnifique interprétation dans un cadre
tout aussi magnifique et je le disais
disponible sur votre chaîne youtube en
intégralité on aura l'occasion sur
l'antenne de tv soixante dix huit au
cours de l'année 2022 de revenir sur vos
différents projets de détailler un peu
plus cette programmation juste pour
conclure j'aime en quelques mots qu'on
parle du volet musique et handicap que
vous menez dans le cadre de votre
travail avec le musée de saint germain
parce que je sais que ça vous tient
particulièrement à coeur oui nous
travaillons avec le monde
particulièrement de l'autisme depuis
plus d'une centaine d'années avec notre
collaboratrice chanteuse et pédagogue de
la voix catherine boni et nous avons
préparé un projet cette année comme nous
le faisons depuis une vingtaine d'années
qui va permettre un partage entre ces
personnes qui ont un accès à un monde
assez incroyable que vous méritez
vraiment de sensibilité à la musique
nous préparons pour le 2 juillet un
voyage au fil du temps qui part bien sûr
de la préhistoire jusqu'à aujourd'hui où
les enfants et les adultes chante un
projet qui est mené avec deux
institutions donc dont des foyers dans
les yvelines de mareil marly et de
croissy sur seine donc chaque semaine
catherine boni va travailler avec eux
chaque mois par dont elle va travailler
avec eux dans des ateliers need et
ensuite c'est de réunir tout le monde et
de faire cette interaction avec les
musiciens de l'ensemble calliopée pour
proposer vraiment un véritable spectacle
c'est un moment assez
extraordinaire justement parce que ces
personnes là elles sont très différentes
mais du coup tout le monde se
rapprochent les familles peuvent voir
que ces personnes peuvent aussi l avoir
accès aux comme tout le public tout le
long de l'année au musée d'archéologie
il est pour tout le monde autant la
musique l'archéologie c'est pour tous
merci beaucoup karine lethiec d'avoir
été avec nous pour cette émission dont
78 sur le programme complet de vos
différents spectacles sur votre site
internet merci encore à vous quittons
saint germain à présent et son musée
pour le trianon de versailles et son
shell et mathilde de franco est allé y
passer l'après-midi un après midi de
détente dans un cadre magnifique
on
[Musique]
je suis actuellement dans la galerie du
trianon palace situé à versailles en
présence du chef pâtissier eddie
benghanem bonjour bonjour à tous
bienvenue au waldorf astoria merci à
écrire le palace merci beaucoup alors
tout d'abord est ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter nous expliquer ce que ce
qu'est le métier de chef pâtissier je
suis chef pâtissier dans ce bel hôtel
depuis quelques années des armes dans
lequel j'officie est en fait mon rôle
est de travailler avec toutes les
équipes de faire plaisir aux clients et
de proposer des gourmandises et des
douceurs tout au long de l'année alors
en face de nous on a ce tea time est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer comment
est ce que vous l'avez penser comment
est ce que vous avez sélectionné
je ratisse tout le titane week-end donc
un parfait glacé exotiques donc on va
commencer par des notes acidulées fruité
légèrement épicé donc ananas frais
exotiques et ensuite on va poursuivre
avec un cac qui est assez moderne donc
là quelques au citron avec les chantiers
au citron on retrouve le liant qui est
un peu sur le kumquat confier les
agrumes et on va finir avec une tarte au
chocolat vanille on dénote extrêmement
simple très visible et le but le plus
important pour nous est vraiment de
faire plaisir à nos clients donc les
pâtissiers montrent le samedi et le
dimanche pour présenter le titane à nos
clients et on voit ce qui se passe donc
le sillage et j'ai aimé ça j'ai pas aimé
ça pour réajuster l'expérience on parle
vraiment d'expérience et faire plaisir
et donc vous avez aussi imaginer la
bûche de noël pour les fêtes de fin
d'année de choses elle est assez
atypique cette bûche de noël est ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer comment vous
l'avez penser comment je les pense et
c'est depuis je l'avais en otage le 10
janvier legal est donc les années
précédentes nous travaillons sur des
bûches assez onirique assez assez
élégante sur des notes végétales et là
je me suis dit j'ai envie de rigoler le
colis de nous a tous marqués donc je
voulais rigoler et je me suis dit
comment prendre la bûche à contre-pied
et je me suis dit mais qu'est ce qu'on
mange à noël qu'est ce qu'est le plat
principal à noël la dinde de noël et je
me suis dit balla laden va pas passer à
la casserole non vous avez le chef qui
n'est pas passée à la casserole c'est
écrit sur son tablier chef donc la
casserole et au chocolat une jolie
casserole avec une imitation de fonte
tout éco msn c'est que du chocolat voilà
donc la casserole et en chocolat le
gâteau est ici donc voilà la gazinière
aller à pas et ça c'est le gâteau les
menus cadeaux sont bannis chocolat
caramel pourquoi ces parfums là ce sont
des parfums les préférés des français
donc en fait nous on va mettre la cloche
la part dont la cocotte sous une cloche
et le client n'aura que ça a conservé au
frigo est en fait la cloche vient se
poser 10 actuellement sur le gâteau donc
c'est un centre de table les gens soient
un petit peu interloqué pendant pendant
le repas musique au scrutin et en faites
vous des clochers voilà et vous
découvrez le gâteau un gâteau pour 6 8
personnes et pour avoir faire le test
sont dégustation syfy personne c'est
super place à la dégustation maintenant
alors eddie benghanem comment ça se
passe je prends la première pondération
est donc il ya un parfait glacé donc on
va commencer par le froid est assez
assez douces acidulées mais douce et
puis je vous en prie à l'asie
donc en fait vous avez vous avez parfait
glacé serbe exotiques les nôtres est
crémeuse très douce acidulées gour monde
mais à l'ananas qui au fond bien sûr
mais à l'intérieur du coup à l'orage sur
l'exotique charme exotique
vous savez le côté un peu fruité
acidulées un peu bonbon d'accord n'est
peut-être pas tout manger
peut prendre notre assiette
là c'est juste un cake ou cake au citron
le le même principe que le tchèque 1-0
qu'un biscuit riche en amande et la
gentille qui au citron dessus les rats
c'est assez c'est beaucoup plus incisive
et bien c'est beaucoup plus puissant
mais c'est le sait le principe d'un
cargo oui on semble beaucoup plus
bas les saveurs de l'oranje du coup oui
citerons entre les versions complètement
est vraiment principe du cake parce que
lucky times et c'est aussi le cake le
fameux cake
c'est très bon
moi c'est mon préféré est celui d'un et
le dernier le dernier démoniaque hymnes
et
là vous prenez le couteau là vous couper
en deux la ta vous allez voir un espace
intérieur en fait à galashiels est cuit
tout doucement au four il ya une crème
brûlée à la vanille et dessus il ya une
crème au chocolat et dont on entendait
le bruit que ça fait quand vous ça
croustille à fond ça c'est bon alors dit
mme jahjaga nage donc la ganache et les
cuites au four d'accord une comme une
crème brûlée ya aussi une crème brûlée à
la vanille d'accord et il ya une crème
légère à la fève de cacao
ça c'est ça c'est super évasive ça
croustille
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de bien mais
c'est très léger oui mais derrière peu
de sucre dont peu de sucre des cuissons
justes
et en même temps lisible pour comprendre
ce qu'on mange ont galvanisé ou alors
d'autres activités sont également de
proposer au trianon palace de versailles
notamment le chalet de noël qui a
installé dans le parc du château est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un petit
peu plus de sûr c'est une petite pause
bourbon avant d'aller se promener dans
le château de versailles nom que vous
pourrez acheter une grignotines un cake
ou une boisson chaude ou ses rangs un
petit clin d'oeil à l'automne
merci beaucoup chef pour ce moment
partagé
vous avez bien attiser nos papilles en
tout cas la somme at il
[Musique]
la brasserie o'clock existe depuis 2015
donc c'est une brasserie qui a été
fondée par trois amis d'enfance donc
quand un kevin et et moi même donc nous
on se connaît depuis qu'on est au
collège et on a brassé notre première
béart quand on était au lycée et à la
fin nos études on a décidé de vraiment
de se lancer dans la brasserie et de
créer notre propre marque et donc la
bière o'clock la brasserie au club
brewing et donc on est installé depuis
2015 à à bois d'arcy pour fabriquer une
bière on va utiliser principalement de
l'eau du malt
du houblon et de la levure une fois
qu'on a assemblé tout ça et qu'on a
mélangé tout ça on lance une
fermentation et on a une bière qui finit
par être une bière en bouteille un petit
peu comme cette comme cette jet lag qui
à nos produits phares qui est la bière
aujourd'hui qu'on vend le plus c'est
notre aie pitié c'est une dire créer à
la fois très aromatique qui développe
pas mal d'amertume l'idée c'est vraiment
de proposer un produit différent de ce
que on connaissait habituellement en
tout cas de différent de ce que faisait
les biens et les brasseurs industriels
ensuite on a voulu développer chez eux
claque une gamme de produits un peu
atypique qui est la gamme baden power
l'idée c'est de faire vieillir les
bières dans des barriques et ses breaks
ont une histoire et c'est de profiter de
l'histoire de cette barrique pour pris
un espèce de l'effet surprise sur nos
soeurs nos produits sur le produit fini
donc en fait on achète des barriques qui
ont compté du cognac du bourbon de la
tequila du rhum et l'idée c'est vraiment
de profiter de ce 2 de ce fait de cette
histoire pour apporter une vraie valeur
ajoutée à nos produits et en créer un
produit très atypique et original nous
rentrons dans la dernière partie de
cette émission avec encore beaucoup de
rencontres de découvertes à partager
avec vous cocktail games où viendra nous
présenter des jeux de société que nous
avons testé ici autour de cette table en
plateau oui patrice vous chanterez passé
sans que patrice à bout font parler de
chanter petit le début de cette émission
à vous chanterez ça nous irons aussi
déguster les meilleurs bûche du
département à versailles auprès de 2
pâtissier de renom et puis philippe
lachaux et sa bande nous parleront de
leur nouveau film qui sortira en février
2022 super héros malgré lui livre les
noix est venu déjà présenté le film au
cours d'avant premières pour l'instant
dernier volet de notre rétro 2021 1
mathilde de francs couche survole les
derniers mois de l'année
le président de la république a chaussé
ses crampons pour disputer la rencontre
du variétés club de france à poissy un
match face aux soignants du centre
hospitalier intercommunal de poissy et
saint-germain-en-laye la fédération
française de cyclisme a décidé de nommer
florian rousseau au poste de directeur
du programme olympique
l'ancien pistard triple champion
olympique aura pour objectif de faire
performer cette équipe de france en 2024
et l'open de france de golf va faire son
grand retour à saint quentin en yvelines
après deux annulations en raison de la
crise sanitaire la compétition aura lieu
en septembre 2022 ça a été officialisée
début novembre un demi milliard d'euros
reversés dans les yvelines depuis le
début du plan relance il ya un an des
fonds attribués à des entreprises des
associations ou des collectivités en
faveur de l'écologie la compétitivité ou
encore la cohésion des territoires côté
politique à lire à b et réguler maire de
trappes après l'annulation de son
élection pour des manquements aux règles
du code électoral sa liste est arrivée
en tête dès le premier tour avec 58% des
suffrages
plusieurs hommages ont été rendus au
professeur d'histoire-géographie samuel
pâtit victime d'une attaque terroriste
l'année dernière devant le collège de
conflans sainte honorine les écoles
évinoise ont décidé d'honorer sa mémoire
avec des cours dédiés à la liberté
d'expression une marche blanche ou
encore un monument en forme de livre
ouvert emmanuel macron est venu
inaugurer la maison zola à médan après
dix ans de travaux la maison de
l'écrivain rouvre ses portes elle est
accompagnée d'un musée dédié à la sphère
dreyfus l'auteur et compositrice
catherine lara s'est vu remettre l'ordre
national du mérite à poissy la ville qui
l'a vu naître
l'automobile de demain se prépare dans
les yvelines un nouveau campus vert pour
la recherche et le développement va
s'installer à poissy la vente du domaine
de gueugnon et suspendu des
mobilisations avait eu lieu en octobre
pour protester contre cette session du
promoteur immobilier altarea cogedim et
le ska et business 17 encore tenu en
ligne cette année en raison du coc vite
19 l'objectif développer l'attractivité
du territoire le gouvernement annonce
l'obligation de la troisième dose du
vaccin pour lutter contre la copie 19
pour lutter face à l'afflux de demandes
plusieurs centres de vaccination
rouvrent leurs portes comme le vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui revient
progressivement à sa capacité maximale
joséphine baker et la sixième femme à
entrer au panthéon mais la première deux
couleurs noir l'artiste
franco-américaine a vécu au vésinet
d'ailleurs après son intronisation une
table ronde était organisée dans la vie
en présence de l'un des fils en campagne
dans les yvelines les cinq candidats au
congrès les républicains ont tenu des
meetings versailles plaisir montigny le
bretonneux ou encore saint cyr l'école
c'est finalement valérie pécresse qui a
remporté la dernière étape du congrès
avec 60 points 95 % des voix la
présidente de la région ile de france
représentera l'est républicain pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 et
enfin plusieurs animations avaient lieu
dans les yvelines pour récolter des
fonds pour le téléthon basket tir à
l'arc ou encore pétanque les villes
étaient mobilisées pour la 35ème édition
et c'est sur ce dernier trimestre 2021
patrice que vous êtes allé chercher
votre personnalité politique de l'année
roulement de tambour il s'agit de hoya
pas mis fin au suspense suspense dans
les yvelines annoncé valérie pécresse
évidemment
[Musique]
oui qu'est qui vous ont rien
d'abord elle été réélue présidente de la
région assez largement à ces cétacés des
pressions voilà que
c'était la première élection avait été
très serré serré la deuxième place alors
c'est vrai dans des circonstances un peu
différente puisqu'il énorme abstentions
cette élection là et puis elle a gagné
donc là la primaire de 2 à l'air c'était
pas gagné d'avancé non plus
bertrand quitté qui était plutôt partant
pendant qu'ils étaient plutôt le le le
favori elle a gagné assez largement ce
qui fait que tout le monde se regroupe
derrière elle une sorte d'unité chez
bébert parce que finalement la droite se
disent ils pensaient pas beaucoup a
depuis cinq ans dit aux fauves à
l'élection et peut-être gagnable cette
fois et c'est vrai qu'elle a des chances
ça dépendra il m'a gardé conditions il
ya des conditions il ya au fond il ya
deux grands courants qui vont qui vont
jouer cette élection deux grands
courants politiques qu'il ya où il ya et
il ya la division et iliad dégagisme la
division c'est on le voit
la droite est divisée il ya au moins le
pen moore il ya valérie pécresse
prenons le charge la droite en la droite
au système au centre et une partie c'est
emmanuel macron c'était il ya trois mois
quand on fait une droite identitaire et
que la droite de le pen et de zemmour il
ya la droite
cliquez la droite est atistes enfin de
qui représenté par par valérie pécresse
puis une droite plus libérale plus
européenne qui représentait bar pas
comment c'est vrai qu'elle est divisée
et puis il ya quand même ce phénomène du
dégagisme qui fait qu'au fond aucun
président qui exerçait réellement le
pouvoir n'a réussi à être réélu sous la
vème république
sauf mitterrand et chirac s'offrit
théorie chirac mais j'ai dit aucun
président qui exerçait réellement le
pouvoir mitterrand et chirac ont été
réélus parce qu'ils étaient des
présidentes de cohabitation ceux qui
exerçaient réellement le pouvoir à ce
moment là c'était chirac qui était le
premier de mitterrand et c'est jospin
qui était le vrai ministre de chirac est
d'ailleurs une élection s'est joué
mitterrand contre chirac et et chirac
contre jospin et des deux premiers
ministres et qui a exercé le pouvoir ont
été battus donc eux aussi ont été des
victimes des dégâts jean donc on verra
est-ce que emmanuel macron va réussir à
renverser cette cette loi du dégagisme
qui a toujours été présente la cinquième
république est ce que est ce que ben la
désunion l'une new va se faire derrière
valérie pécresse ça sera l'un des enjeux
de cette prévenir un long jeu aussi de
l'extrême droite est ce que les deux
candidatures qui se maintiennent entre
eric zemmour et marine le pen très
moyenne c'est ça aussi qui permet
d'être avec race c'est la présence
d'eric zemmour qui prend effectivement
plus du côté du du rassemblement
national que du côté de la droite
républicaine il ya de la bonne image
aussi tout de même de valérie pécresse
vous l'avez dit réélu plus largement
présidente de région est ce que ça peut
lui servir sur ce scrutin alors c'est
très ambigu c'est parce qu'elle a une
bonne image de gestionnaire de l'île de
france et en même temps c'est une
élection nationale et vous savez que
tout ce qui vient de paris par forcément
très bien vu en province donc il va
falloir qu'elle avait dénoncées vous
pensez à quelqu'un en particulier non
mais c'est vrai il ya toujours cette
cette dichotomie la province contre
paris quoi même donc il faut qu'elle
profite de dub à cette image de bonnes
gestionnaires et en même temps faut qu
elle détache un peu l'image peut-être et
de et de l'ile-de-france et de
versaillaise aussi enfin voilà donc ça
va être aussi un des enjeux de cette
élection le scrutin qui fera sur
l'affectif aussi peut-être un petit peu
alors voilà ça c'est assez intéressant
parce que si vous avez regardé manuel
macron dans son salon et interviews lui
aussi est il avait on considérait un peu
comme valérie pécresse est considéré
comme une bonne élève elle était sortie
deuxième de l'ena et hec elle après le
russe enfin elle c'est une très
brillante élève mais ça suffit pas pour
être président de la république et
regardez ce que fait macron qu'est-ce
qu'il dit aujourd'hui il dit plus c'est
langage technocratique c'est je n'ai
jamais autant aimé la france j'aime les
français je n'ai jamais autant aimé des
français il va placer sa campagne sur le
le registre affectif est-ce que valérie
pécresse sera capable
de fondre l'armure ses dires de da voilà
il faut se montrer quand on quand on
veut être président ou présidente de la
république il a fait un pas important ça
craque latics a très bien joué aussi
ben oui il faut il faut l'arroser lui
ces rennais m'a d'ailleurs c'est lui qui
a pris à pécresse a ses raisons la grèce
a tout appris ce que commencé en
politique avec jacques chirac d'ailleurs
mais il faut il faut après ce livret
s'est passé pas un exercice forcément
facile et pas forcément un exercice
auquel elle est vraiment habitués ont su
grâce à cette élection présidentielle et
notamment le parcours de valérie
pécresse la présidente de la région ile
de france sur les premiers mois de
l'année prochaine on va changer
d'univers complètement à présent avec
une invitée qui va nous rejoindre en
plateau elle représente la société
yvelinoise veut avec vous avec nous
pardon vous installez la société
yvelinoise cocktail games nous recevons
sarah m'excuserai décrocher d'accrocher
un petit peu votre nom de famille ben
barka voilà en charge de la
communication et du développement de la
marque cocktail games une entreprise de
jeux basés sur versailles autour de
cette table vous connaissez peut-être
quelques-uns des jeux on en a parlé
brièvement tout à l'heure je sais comme
moi c'était parce que je peux chanter
moi c'est chabada
jamais le jeu phare de votre entreprise
c'est top ten déjà peut-être commencer
par le top ten classique et nous leur
présenter un petit peu alors tu appelles
classique donc c'est un party game donc
c'est à dire un jeu d'ambiance dans le
jargon des jeux de société c'est un jeu
coopératif donc tous les joueurs sont
ensemble jouent ensemble gagne ensemble
perdant semble surtout s'amusent
ensemble
je vais vous montrer aussi l'intérieur
donc comme tous les les jeux de cocktail
games est un jeu avec une règle très
rapide très courte on souhaite toujours
faire des jeux simples d'accès
aux passants voilà c'est la règle c'est
la règle joyeusement
salamina numéro autour de la table c'est
un grand exemple est ce assez pour
savoir comment on est si on est bon ou
pas donc ça c'est pareil on alors si les
joueurs ensemble il n'y a pas qu'un seul
gagnant par là c'est l'équipe patrice de
juges chanter non non non je dis
non alors celui ci on va le mettre de
côté maintenant il ya comme seule équipe
qui ne sait pas on est tous ensemble en
fait le principe du jeu c'est dans
autour de la table il ya un capitaine
qui va changer selon les manches donc ce
captain va choisir un thème donc parmi
les cartes je vais vous montrer de
matériel en même temps
là on est par exemple si on joue tous
ensemble on est 5 voilà on est tous des
licornes et jeux sont bien dans leur
corps voilà derrière attention là des
petites crottes faut pas se tromper
donc on choisit un thème sous là si vous
voulez
patrice choisissent un thème voilà je
vous donne des cartes et vous en
choisissez un adacore faudra lire à voix
haute il faudra après assumer ce choix
du thème patrice et le faire c'est un
classique c'est facile alors pour
tricher en classe vous avez caché une
antisèche sûr vous me mais comment vous
la regardez de l'endroit le moins
pratique au plus pratique j'en oublie
que soit opté non
je vais vous distribuer des cartes qui
vont de 1 à 10 donc je vais mélanger
vous allez regarder secrètement il va
falloir énoncer avoir août la réponse
adaptée à notre numéro avec un plat par
exemple 2 1 le 1 c'est le moins visible
c'est ça oui du de l'endroit le moins
pratique et moins pratique bonjour
atlantique en pratique c'est nous les
soutenons quoi le moins théâtre six mois
la pratique et le goût de la classe
etc dont on est ensemble on est tous
ensemble et on doit penser celui qui
veut commencer qu'il commence sa
[Rires]
compagnie des alpes est un exemple voilà
à 5
moore et amy mis d'accord et ensuite
normalement comme vous êtes le capitaine
vous auriez retard mis dans l'ordre les
réponses en tout cas essayer de remettre
dans leur les réponses et à chaque
erreur on retourne une licorne sur la
phase kaka voilà bien voilà on essaie
mon pratique plus pratique alors je
commence mois à rivaliser
j'ai triché pas beaucoup
vanté
[Rires]
ça c'est pour le jeu top ten ça c'est le
jeu top ten normal ça c'est le jeu top
ten normal on a là rien aucun le
principe il y en a un palanquin comme
dit patrice je vais vous laisser le
sortir juste aux mêmes heures précisé
que la société est née en 2003
aujourd'hui ces cinq cent mille ventes
annuelles et un chiffre d'affaires en
hausse constante et donc la société
marche très très bien
nous présenter l'autre topten alors la
tablette lg oui autrichien saint perdon
mais vous allez avoir l'occasion justin
de participer au top ten des idées
allez c'est facile de lancer des maisons
de jeux de société parce qu'il ya des
grosses boîtes quand même il ya des
grosses boîtes
comme les lycéens est un indépendant
encore et
le jeu c'est quelque chose qui s'est
énormément démocratiser la actuellement
surtout avec le confinement notamment ma
topten est sortie pendant le confinement
pensais que ça allait pas lui faire du
bien mais en fait finalement si c'était
plus en famille et entre amis parce que
pendant le conflit n'a été les apéros et
vous abaissez est sûre sur précieuses
sur les sur les sur les ordinateurs sur
les
cdu plutôt des jeux de cartes de société
c'était à prendre il ya certains jeux de
société qui sont utilisés avec des
applications mais nous c'est pas du tout
notre brave au coeur de
l'asie devrait donc à modern maintien
c'est quoi une thématique 18 +18 plus
alors en fait lorsqu'on a sorti ce soap
ten pour l'éditer le développement était
long et on a testé c'était la chanson du
pur pour ce thème le vin ce jeu il ya
500 m en 6 ans entame ici on en a testé
plus de 1000 donc ça a été mis du temps
avec des joueurs de tout univers tout
horizon donc dans les barrages eux dans
les ludothèques et dans ces tests on
s'est rendu compte que les gens des
rappels généralement dans les réponses
et réclamaient des thèmes un peu plus
caliente et du coup
aucun son patrimoine a aucun donc on a
voulu
après dans une émission familiale
on a créé 10 pour leur faire plaisir et
on les avait mis en même temps dans tous
les tests à faire et on s'est rendu
compte que c'est ces thèmes là été
choisit systématiquement joué et rejoué
et on s'est rendu compte que dans une
boîte familiale c'était peut-être pas
une bonne idée donc on les a mis de côté
on a sorti la version d'origine et en
fait on a réussi à trouver appareils des
thèmes et pimenté à foison on en a aussi
500 qu'on a tous testés il faut savoir
que dans les deux boîtes un thème sur
quatre c'est des bruitages des mimes des
petits
temmar à katyn est ravie j'ai
l'impression d'être à mes questions là
c'est parce qu est-ce qu on est passé un
message à vos parents si vous ne
regardez et bien justement me regarder
cette chaîne regardez ce qu'il a sonné
les exemples de thèmes alors sur celui
ci
allait à la licorne est censuré
carrément alors oui ils ont un petit peu
changé de tête on va avoir quelques
quelques visuels aussi voit la montre et
puis quelques visuels qui vont
s'afficher aussi à l'écran
l'exemple de thèmes d autres voient déjà
les thèmes qui existe
à cela ça va garder les dents serrées
dit mon appareil dentaire s'est coincé
dans
compléter le moins étonnant
voilà
la deuxième je suis le deuxième
allez-y mais je vais bien évidemment non
pas du tout patrice voulez vous les avez
le deuxième
tout à fait là ça marche mieux zapper
sur la td pacino bordeaux aux tic en vue
que regardez-vous où vous vous masturbez
voir cette émission et flipkens au plus
excitant très bien
donner les chiffres
on peut chanter aussi vous chantez à the
voice mais le jury ne se retourne pas
chanter de un peu faux attrait faux elle
est pour vous c'est sa chapelle
c'est très vert pour boire danser le
long
le top ten 18 plus comment il marche en
termes de ventes celui ci l'est il vient
de sortir donc la remise il est assez
récent il date de cette fin d'année 2021
il fonctionne très bien il a faim il
suit les traces de son grand frère même
si lui il vient d'avoir 18 ans il est
très il fonctionne très bien avec les
amis effectivement avec la famille un
peu moins placement bien bas ça peut
marcher si on a des familles ouvert qu
on a toujours sur les cartes fait intel
ces flux classique pas un prêt pour ça
que regardez-vous
le cette lisbonne d'intrigués les héros
c'est vous le placez dans le quadruple
coûteux le plus seulement un week-end
pendant que les émissions de la chaîne
avec vous prenez des cours sur la
sexualité pour être encore meilleur qui
est votre coach personnelle de la
personne la moins expérimentée à la plus
expérimentée enfin petit os ou pas
c'est compliqué c'est un an
si on a un c'est bien vous avez un et
non
ça c'est pour le top ten des ssii plus
bon bah on va juste terminée avec un
dernier jeu parce que encore une fois la
crise on l'entend dire ce serait envie
de chanter non j'ai tenté de se
présenter par le chabada sabah lavalard
c'est encore un
un jeu pas un party game est un jeu
d'ambiance où là il faut chanter donc ça
s'adresse ce soit qui aiment
effectivement le karaoke chanter mais
aussi à ceux qui n'apprécient pas
forcément de pousser la chansonnette par
nous parce que c'est un jeu en équipe
donc là il ya deux équipes donc y'a pas
de soucis à un gagnant à la fin du jeu
quand les gens
et c'est un jeu assez simple oubli qui
dit qu'il gagne comme qui dit qu'on
gagne à bâle et là les points à la fin
de la partie ont été distribués les
points
contre 2 way qui va dire par exemple
c'est une paire au champagne hugot bien
oui voilà c'est ça non abri c'est pas
bien ou bien chantôme a chanté non non
c'est par exemple ok il ya un mot qui en
tire une carte sur cette carte il ya
deux mots donc un en français et un en
anglais donc la noël voilà noël
[Musique]
peut faire un petit peu de musical entre
deux équipes mais le premier qui sèchent
pas perdre la carte électorale autres
écrits plus possible voilà exactement
battle musicale non seulement
voilà pourquoi d'autres comme nous avec
un appoint exemple les notes ma gueule
ou pretty qu'est ce qu'elle a ma gueule
c'est trop sur ses troupes un attentat
en général ça marche et ça nous avait
pas prêté une praticienne ça marchait
[Musique]
yahoo ça marche alors la fuite de faire
un expert peut chanter faux on peut
essayer de briller bien là m6 a accepté
par l'autre équipe ça fonctionne pas en
filles ont mis l on faisait un peu trop
la fille aux yeux menthe à l'eau
avec tout compte encore une analyse non
c'est bien c'est donc un non pour
pimenter encore la chose on a mis des
challenge où on peut ou pas ne les faire
à part entière le challenge chez le
dentiste ou faut chanter a gelé dans
chéri comme chez
moi facile voilà comment face il ya le
challenge iame nakamura ou faut
remplacer le mot par dja dja et si on le
fait pas on perd la carte les jo
topten topten 18 plus chabada trois
idées de jeux de la société à caudebec
donne un cocktail games bout et j'ai pas
les dents serrées pourtant pour pour ces
fêtes de fin d'année et puis au delà
bien évidemment c'est à souffrir et est
à découvrir ensuite en famille ou entre
amis merci beaucoup d'être venu mince
très bien ça y est tous là en
tout au long de l'émission nous avons
fait à découvrir les richesses
gastronomiques du territoire nous allons
à présent passer au dessert les chanceux
du jour il en faut toujours bixente
mélanie ils sont allés rencontrer deux
grands pâtissiers à versailles
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui avec mélanie
nous ne sommes pas collègues nous sommes
adversaires deux équipes qui vont
s'affronter pour le combat du meilleurs
desserts de noël et bixente je sais pas
si vous savez notre 8 et 10 millions de
bus ont commandé chaque année ce qui
pousse les pâtissiers à rivaliser
toujours plus d'imagination pour trouver
de nouvelles recettes encore plus
gourmande mélanie mou serait donc dans
l'équipe de la reine astrid et moi même
celle de la pâtisserie fine à versailles
et puis pas plus de mots partout suite à
meudon c'est là où se trouve le
laboratoire de christophe bertrand
[Musique]
christophe vertement bonjour bonjour
alors cette année dans vos préparations
vous avez choisi le mucilage de cacao
est ce qu'on peut tout de suite levé le
voile de ce même sillage oui c'est
quelque chose que les consommateurs ne
connaissent pas et qui va être assez
surprenant parce que ils vont donc mangé
une bûche dont la totalité et fut de la
cabosse tout vient de la cabosse et à
l'intérieur du fruit et une petite pulpe
blanche qui entoure les fèves de cacao
cette petite pile peu blanche va servir
elle est super sucre et en ça ressemble
à du kiwi l'aloe vera du litchi là ça
sent un peu la banane on mange des
fruits alors on mange du fruit mais
justement donc ça veut dire que sachant
que c'est un fruit et comme il faut
manger cinq fruits et légumes tous les
jours lorsque vous manger du chocolat
puis ça c'est moi qui l'ait décidé eh
bien ça rentre dans les fruits et
légumes qu'il faut manger tous les jours
ça va donner l'eau à la bouche
votre chef pâtissier match up et il va
nous révéler la recette moi je vais
aller du côté du labo et il va falloir
que je résiste je pense
mathieu bonjour je remets ma miss et
vous quel est non révélé les secrets de
cette bûche première étape j'imagine
bourré alors aujourd'hui on est sur le
mucilage donc on va faire notre insert
mucilage on perd notre mucilage on va la
faire chauffer on va le monter un petit
peu en température je vais gardien
j'ai du mal à résister montceau mise
notre moule une petite couche de crème
voilà là on a le crémeux qui va apporter
un petit peu d'amertume je viens ferme
et délicatement votre guise
donc j'ai fait une gâtine brouille cacao
confond petit monde de chocolat fèves de
cacao on savait pas mais il y en a
vraiment de toutes les couleurs et à
divers des jaunes des roses enfin des
rouges et la vague rock maintenant on
peut savourer on peut savoir c'est le
moment de déguster merci mathieu voilà
les bus sont déjà disponibles dans les
boutiques de la reine astrid bixente ah
vous de relever le défi parce que là ya
du niveau
mélanie vont à la demande et du niveau
je vous ai pris au mot il est passé par
alain ducasse la maison dalloyau et
l'hôtel ritz à paris mesdames et
messieurs sébastien serveau bonjour
bonjour donc pourquoi vous êtes vous
lancé dans ce défi d'ouvrir votre propre
institut basse a toujours été un rêve en
fait d'ouvrir une pâtisserie avec avec
ma femme et c'est vrai que j'ai traversé
un petit peu le monde pendant une
dizaine d'années avec mon métier de
consultant international et voilà il
était temps de s'installer et à
versailles c'est vrai que ça nous
correspondait bien sûr le côté chic et
haut de gamme de la ville au menu
justement 5 buts l'exotique l'impérial
la saint louis et une petite spécificité
une bûche voilà une année oui je propose
une biche finesse donc avec un moulin
peu spécifique un peu en forme de
torsades cette année ses pommes
spéculoos donc des parfums peu régressif
et que tout le monde apprécie en règle
générale je vous propose d'ailleurs
d'aller voir l'étape l'élaboration de
cette bûche tout de suite bien là j'ai
fait en fait un thé et je vais le verser
sur mes pommes pour faire infuser en
fait mes pommes alors si on a un autre
mode à but donc c'est bien donc ça ça
doit être taillée vraiment la perfection
pour voilà il fera encore très bien
exactement ensuite je vais piocher dans
mon crime au spéculoos ensuite je vais
prendre mes pommes délicatement je vais
les poser dans mon moule ensuite je vais
refermer donc valu avec votre parti de
biscuits donc là je réalise la mousse
vanille de tahiti donc là on est une
heure plus tard un cerf a été sorti du
grand froid et on va pouvoir commencer
vraiment l'assemblage pl je vais masquer
le moule à remonter la mousse sur les
extrémités et ensuite je vais rabattre
un petit peu la moue ses maîtres le
postillon je vais la passe est
maintenant grand froid voilà mes
d'années notre but c'est maintenant
terminé du côté du niveau je pense que
ça va être difficile de nous départager
et vous qu'est-ce que vous choisissez
des filles de buch qui a gagné quelques
bûches vous allez les deux sur
deuxième balle
et les deux les deux sont les pires à
table avec les à goûter aussi
alors voilà je vous l'annonçais nous y
arrivons 2022 9 février philippe lachaux
et sa bande seront à l'affiché du film
super héros malgré lui livre linois qui
a grandi à la celle saint cloud a déjà
présenté le film lors d'avant-premières
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines où
nous l'avons rencontré avec une partie
de son équipe voici l entretien qu'il
nous a accordé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
immersion justesse que vous êtes soulagé
de toutes ces avant-premières qui se
passe plus que bien on rigole beaucoup
c'est très familial on s'amuse écoute
concernant les avant premières j'avoue
que ça se passe très bien et que ça fait
plaisir de voir autant de monde venir
voir le film rires nous dire des choses
si gentille après bon le film est
toujours pas sorti donc voilà mais en
tout cas pour l'instant ça se passe
super bien effectivement quand tu vas
aux avant premières tu as toujours ce
stress de dire est ce que le film va
plaire plus que les autres commente les
autres
voilà est bon pour l'instant tout se
passe très bien je m'appelle cédric je
suis comédien et une passe et le casting
du rôle de ma vie pas de malheur à la
base j'étais pas le premier choix alors
pour moi manman sétois moitié
ni grâce à un petit coup de pouce du
destin
badman c'est moi
le premier super héros
français un mois sur le pitch on n'en a
pas parlé donc un apprenti comédien qui
décroche enfin un premier rôle je de
circonstance et qui devient badman un
accident il confond fiction fiction et
réalité s'identifier à son personnage on
sent que vous vous amusez tous beaucoup
j'aurais juste avoir la vie d'elodie
fontan aussi au milieu tous ces garçons
vous vous amusez beaucoup aussi
c'est plus ça demande plus de
concentration évidemment pour philippe
qui est réalisateur mais nous on est les
clowns à côté ouais c'est ça il a besoin
d'être très concentré alors que d'autres
pas du tout donc c'est là qu'on s'amuse
beaucoup on a des personnages très
différents à chaque fois voilà j'ai la
chance de faire une militaire qui est
très loin de moi avec des tatouages avec
plein de collier enfin voilà un
personnage qui ne ressemble plus du coup
donc on s'est éclaté julien pareil ton
personnage capillairement te ressemble
pas beaucoup oui j'ai des cheveux donc
c'est une nouveauté pour moi la
référence sur ce film là ce sont tous
les super héros quand vous écrivez le
film et sur la conception du film parce
que les références un nombre
incalculable de référence au film de
super héros est ce que vous vous
l'imposer dans l'écriture ou est ce que
ça vient tout seul les références à tous
ces films là c'est à dire que
effectivement même mettre des petits
clins d'oeil plus ou moins évident pour
les gens qui connaissent les films de
super héros
et après nos collègues qui venait de
façon naturelle et après il y en a c'est
vrai on se disait tiens ce serait bien
quand même de placer ce personnage là où
cette chose parce que c'est quand même
mais c'est très emblématique et du coup
on essaie de trouver à quel moment dans
quelle scène place et ça
donc voilà un peu un peu des deux je
peux pas faut le dire est ce que c'est
ça
[Musique]
comment de tous les spermatozoïdes y
avaient péri mais le premier comment
vous allez travailler sur l'écriture
globale du film aussi avec un stylo et
un papier non c'est assez basique à on
se retrouve toujours chez philippe et sa
compagne qui est contente de nous et de
nous accueillir tous les jours et on est
quatre à écrire donc il ya pierre
lachaud le petit frère de fille qui
adore qu'on appelle le petit frère et
pierre du dans ce fichier mois et on
écrive c'est assez scolaire on se
retrouve le matin on travaille toute la
journée des fois il ya plein d'idées
d'autres fois il y en a - voilà et on a
un parasite qui vient et qui écrit sur
des fois on a un peu peur bird qui écrit
elle met le prénom de son personnage par
exemple as they eléonore eléonore fait
la bagarre et l'honneur tape sur l'un
voilà je ne citerai pas je ne dirais pas
qui c'est sur le département quand même
un mot pour le département des yvelines
département où vous avez grandi
vous aimez bien revenir aussi sur le
département vous salue et souvent aller
votre professeur la dernière fois moi
j'ai vu le film à plaisir avant première
un plaisir professeur de sport qui
étaient présents ouais c'était beaucoup
en fait on vient du ce sont 18 on a
passé nos parmi nos meilleures années
dans le 78 avec wifi et du coup
forcément quand on revient ici qu'on
présente le film dans les yvelines on
est hyper content ça nous touche et puis
ça nous fait quelque chose donc c'est
important pour nous nouria de la celle
saint cloud donc nous les cinémas à
l'époque c'était cinéma de parler d'eux
on y aller tout le temps puis voilà on y
allait en bande et tout donc ouais
retour aux sources on adore je veux pas
trop en dévoiler sur ce film là j'aurais
juste voir par rapport au prochain est
ce que vous avez déjà l'idée du prochain
ma question est un peu orienté fait
regarder sur internet des gens ont déjà
des idées le prochain ce serait une
adaptation d'astérix par la bande à fifi
j'ai vu un sondage sur mesopinions.com
il ya trois signatures pour cette
adaptation est ce que c'est une bonne
idée ou pas trois signatures l'instant
il ya
des banques qui si une guêtre la chaux
gérard la chaux
et voilà
non il coûte pour te dire la vérité il
ya un
un moment nous avait approché un peu
pour astérix voilà notre c'était trop
tôt parce qu'on avait on estimer pas
avoir fait grand chose et et le prochain
tout cas on tournait les prochaines la
suite d'alibi pour le besoin d'éviter un
dîner avec les beaux-parents je vais
vous voir pour un ami marié et il vient
de rencontrer une jeune femme avec qui
il faudrait peut être parti en week-end
comment s'appelle votre ami son prénom
il s'appelle jean jean claude jusqu'au
jour où j'ai rencontré mon beau père
juste une toute dernière question ce
qu'il y aura une suite ou non à nicky
larson je vous pose la question parce
que j'ai trois filles à la maison qui
ont vu chacune au moins dix fois le film
et qui me le demandent qu'ils
connaissaient pas mais je ne connaissais
pas mais du coup moi je connaissais on a
pu échanger dessus mais écoute ce qui
est intéressant c'est que nicky larson
c'est pas le film qu'on a faits qui a le
plus marché ça a marché mais c'est pas
celui qui a le plus marché et je crois
que c'est le film dans les avant
premières a dû faire 50 salles
jusqu'aujourd'hui on nous demande à
chaque fois sirène suite anick arsenault
que ben on sait que y aura au moins 53
personnes avec des filles voilà donc non
mais ça fait plaisir parce que le projet
avait tellement été un peu décrié à
l'annonce pas la sortie mais à la noce
que du coup ça fait plaisir avec un
parallèle avec 4 size way éventuellement
c'est vrai ce qu'on dit sur vous vous
êtes le meilleur des gardes du corps
vous pouvez tirer cimbal au même endroit
on crée des personnes aussi des rennais
fille comme celui à qui on fait appel
l'an dernier
je crois que mon frère se prend pour le
personnage de son film de super héros
il est parti terminé sa mission c'est
ainsi que nous allons refaire mais cette
émission fin du 78 tours spécial fin
d'année donc maintenant l'occasion aussi
de vous souhaiter de bonnes fêtes aux
uns et aux autres et à tous ceux qui
nous suivent on se retrouve très vite
ans en 2022 pour vivre l'actualité du
département sur tv 78 excellente fête
est à vous également et on se retrouve
très vite sur notre antenne
[Musique]